[Musique]
stéphane rotenberg
[Applaudissements]
et c'est bien ce type alors
je ne vais pas sauter
à quoi servent ces des carcasses brûlées
ressemble à qui elles imputent le bois
c'est tom cruise quand j'étais une
superstar séméacais ou sept hommes tous
alors on va passer de cetto qui aura la
plus longue venez avec moi stéphane
rotenberg
on va prendre tous les deux un [ __ ] ici
pas mal tiré
il ya bien sûr c'est comme la courte
paille sans lui qui a la plus courte et
bien voilà bien jusqu'à la plus longue
d'ailleurs pourra donc plus longue
voilà donc la voilà on l'a on commence
avec sa faune et la rouge pas mal je
suis pas mal
elle est pas mal
baird ah ouais c'est la même chose que
la bnf carrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là la regarder là on a sa façon pas du
tout la musique est formidable bien ça y
est ce une cata merde allez y ça passe
ça passe oh merde voilà c'est bon nabila
et stéphane stephen je sais que tu es un
aventurier chez que d'un sportif on a
déjà joué au tennis ensemble pas surpris
si 0 c'est pas grave ce ne sera pas le
seul
c'est parti sa tournée au liban sais pas
la france
[Rires]
allez on y va
stéphane mongeau la carotte de l'amitié
allez c'est ça allait enfin attention le
qui aura la plus longue
stéphane alesi choisissez le perdant
devra se mettre là et le gagnant aura
une petite tige et bien sûr voilà voilà
mais c'est très sympa vous inquiétez pas
ma gueule et gary va embêter
oui j'ai un deal à vous faire si vous
prenez ma place demain je dirais toutes
les missions toutes les cinq minutes qui
a qui est la taupe sur m6 ajoute je
prends bon bah voilà allez c'est bon bah
voilà
allez merci et ben voila merci stéphane
je vais s'amuse à toutes les 5 minutes
seront dispensés par terre que j'attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]